If we waned to emphasize long term trends in our data,
rather than year to year variability we might plot a loess curve
over our data points. Loess is a form of weighted regression.
We won't go into it too much in this course, but you
can see here that it captures the overall trends in our
Red Sox data rather than the year to year effects. So we
see that the themes were getting better up until the 80s,
got a bit worse in the 90s, and have continued to improve
in the 2000s. Adding this line makes it easier to take a quick
look at our chart and come away with an understanding of the big
picture. Where as if we just had the points or have the lines
connecting each point, it requires a little more heavy lifting by the viewer.